j'aimerais avoir l'avis de yann moix là
dessus et après j'aimerais avoir le
témoignage de loi déjà un cyril les
chiffres d'homicides qui baissent en 20
ans ne veulent rien dire imaginez qu'on
dise que les infarctus ont baissé si
pendant ce temps là les cancers du
pancréas sont explosés des tumeurs au
cerveau et les avc aussi ça ne prouve
donc rien la deuxième chose c'est que
les chiffres ne montrent pas les
intentions le brésil que je connais très
bien une société 50 fois plus violente
que la france mais une grande différence
cyril le problème de la france n'est pas
la violence en tant que tel c'est la
gratuité de cette violence au brésil
quand les gamins vous plantent leur
flingue sur la tempe
c'est pour avoir de l'argent en france
il ya une violence d'une immense
gratuité qu'est ce qui fait qu'on va tu
laisses et tué un chauffeur de bus
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on va essayer
d'agresser quelqu'un qui vous demande de
mettre un masque et cette gratuité
je l' ai vu et je les lui dans
l'histoire du paris saint-germain regard
alors justement
imaginez si rim ait fait une expérience
et par l'extrême juste après vous avoir
les est ce que vous allez nous expliquer
après regardez les extraits c'est les
violences sur les champs elysées lors de
la défaite du psg c'est le 23 août
dernier
dès la fin du match les champs elysées
se sont transformées en champ de
bataille
d'un côté les forces de l'ordre et puis
de l'autre des supporters et des
fauteurs de troubles
très vite des groupes de jeunes jettent
des bouteilles de verre ou tirs des
mortiers de feu d'artifices sur les
forces de l'ordre voitures incendiées
vitrines de magasins cas ces commerces
pillés
les échauffourées dure plusieurs heures
dans la capitale
le ministre de l'intérieur français
dénonce ce site la sauvagerie de
certains délinquants alors jan c'est une
expérience de pensée déconnecter
complètement cette violence du match en
quoi le match est il concerné par cette
violence
vous supprimez mentalement le match il
n'ya plus que cette violence là et c'est
pas difficile de les séparer parce
qu'ils n'ont aucun rapport
dire que la prochaine étape ce sera
exactement ça sent le prétexte du match
avant et ça s'appelle la guerre civile